[Musique]
les lieux culturels sont dans l'attenté
d'une réponse définitive pour redémarrer
la machine ce jeudi le porte parole du
gouvernement a confirmé aux échos
une réouverture partielle a laminé les
musées pourraient être les premiers à
rouvrir leurs portes se tester soi même
au coc u19 c'est désormais possible
depuis lundi la vente des autotests est
autorisée en pharmacie l'arrêté du
ministère a été publié dimanche au
journal officiel
plusieurs pharmacies yvelinoise ne sont
pas encore approvisionnées les
agriculteurs yvelinois n'ont pas été
épargné par le gel qui a touché
l'ensemble du pays
des températures négatives tardif qui
ont causé de nombreux dégâts dans les
exploitations
un impact qui s'expliquait par un choc
thermique après le reportage de
complément d'enquêté sur l'entreprise
atos révélant la présence de cancer du
cerveau parmi le personnel
la mairie des clayes-sous-bois contacter
la rs pour mesurer l'exposition aux
ondes électromagnétiques dans la ville
des mesures qui se sont avérées en
dessous des normes la piscine de mignot
a rouvert à poissy après presque six
mois de fermeture le bassin extérieur
est de nouveau accessible protocole
sanitaire oblige une jauge maximale de
nageurs et des créneaux ont été mis en
place
[Musique]